meet the world cup winner with arguably
the best background story less than a
year ago Borussia mönchengladbach
Christoph Kramer was still playing in
the second division his inclusion in
yogi loves world cup squad came as a
complete surprise but because of a
teammate's injury he was in the starting
lineup in the final at the Maracana but
after just 17 minutes he collided with
Argentina's Ezekiel garai and suffered a
concussion cropper kept playing for a
few minutes but has few memories of that
day we asked him about them the guns of
a whole world watched the world cup
final but you didn't yeah if the enemy I
watched it on TV afterward of course it
was a shame if you can really say shame
or anything negative about a day like
that because everything was really
positive I was in the starting lineup
and was doing relatively well before I
was forced to leave so early what can
you still remember from the game on I
remember everything up to the collision
and in the second half they let me back
on the bench again I remember all of
that but in between I've got amnesia
those memories probably won't come back
no this was all a little more than a
month ago looking at it now how has
winning the World Cup changed you to
defend us mmm i'd say it hasn't changed
me personally at all I'm still the same
person still the same player but I
notice a greater respect why this is I
don't know but people just come off a
little bit odd in the way they relate to
me cool however for a while it didn't
look like your career was headed toward
the World Cup I'm thinking about when
you were 16 and were dumped by
Leverkusen's youth team back then did
you still believe you'd be a success
onion position of our globe mmm an
imposition if I believed I'd be
successful I've always believed in
myself but not this kind of success I
remember when I was 15 or 16 my goal
to make a living from football somehow
that was my motivation because i
remember a regional league match at
fortuna dusseldorf the atmosphere there
was fantastic and that became my goal I
couldn't have imagined how far beyond
that things would go when I was coming
to us I my funding anything by that well
back then when you were dropped from the
team is it true you started a diary yeah
I was nothing well Diary is a big word
let's just say that I jotted down a few
thoughts after every game my coach at
the time suggested this because he
couldn't really remember his youth and
the games he was in and those are of
course really great memories reading it
brings back things I've sometimes
forgotten and that's great that's fine
what do you write down I buzzed over
certain moments as a kid you will often
remember the day-to-day matters but not
the important things and we can have
vivid images in our memory that we've
seen when we were young even if that
moment was nothing special mint garnish
pizzelles la this is so important is
memory in football and cold foods by
yellow man nations gotta say I think
it's very important you always need to
know where you come from what you've
done for it and how it all came about I
also know that I'm very lucky in my
career I've been very ambitious and I've
worked hard none of that is a matter of
chance even if pure luck has played a
role out of my notebook traces that
quite well over the seven years
vocalizes a second school to when you
see me alpha chi minh and football
there's a saying you should only look
forward never back what's on this
edition that's nonsense mine in general
people only remember the good times so
they say everything was better in the
past that's why most people look back
fondly on their school days but they're
only thinking about the nice things that
happen
and they forget the day-to-day drudgery
it's a bit of a mistake because in
business on toothless could you give a
colleague of mine recently bet 10 euros
that gladbach would prevail in the
league you know how much he would win if
they did Don 320 not even close 1000
euros we're not that 101 worth ago no
one's easy one oh well I didn't I don't
know if it's worth it neither yoga's
going makeup them if gladbach win the
league it would but otherwise the 10
euros are gone right so i wouldn't put
more than 10 euros on